monsieur le doyen quels sont les thèmes
essentiels de la réunion d'information
il vient au terme d'une année
universitaire la sanction normale et
l'examen basé sur le type d'enseignement
dispensées au cours de l'année il est
impensable de pénaliser les étudiants
après une paix et une année de travail
ceci n'implique pas qui ne sera pas
apporté des modifications profondes sur
le plan de la pédagogie et sur celui du
contrôle des connaissances dans l'avenue
le désir de passer les examens a été
exprimée par les étudiants du cpm dans
une proportion qui a pu atteindre
jusqu'à 93%
il est impensable que pour des raisons
très discutable le déroulement de ces
examens soient perturbées par certains
nous nous attachons à ce que ces examens
se déroulent dans le calme et tenons à
assurer les étudiants que la grande
majorité des enseignants est décidé à de
profondes réformes dans un proche avenir
qu'ils viennent donc confiants en eux
mêmes et en douce la nation ne
comprendrait pas que les connaissances
du futur médecin ne soit pas l'objet
d'une vérification rigoureuse